Next up, let's create a camera switch blueprint and with the blueprint what we'll do is we'll
set up a view target with some kind of blending going on so you can figure out how to set
cameras and blend from one camera to another.
We'll use a flip-flop node which is essentially a pick A and then pick B output and then repeat
itself so it goes A, B, A, B. We'll talk about arrays and how to use arrays so that's
a series of cameras in an array and then we'll talk about the multi gate node which can essentially
fire a different output with each input coming in.
So say you have a flow of information coming into a gate you can say okay output gate one,
output gate two, output gate three and it's essentially just helps figure out your flow
within Blueprint.
And again we're going to create a new Blueprint so I'm just going to right click and going
to go to Blueprint and I'm going to select actor first and I'm going to type BP underscore
camera switch.
Then the name doesn't necessarily matter so whichever you'd like to do I'm going to hit
enter to open it or you can double click.
I'm just going to make sure I save it first and foremost.
So the first thing we want to do is figure out how to change the view target with a blend.
So we want to blend maybe from the player character to a different camera that's based
in the scene.
So I'm going to go to the event graph.
I'm going to find some new space just right clicking and moving around.
I'm going to first get player controller and the player controller so this bottom option
here get player controller.
Want to select that and the camera data for the player inside of Unreal is housed on the
controller so whenever you want to interact with the player's camera you want the controller
here.
So we're going to drag off the blue line here and we'll type set view target with blend.
So I'll hit enter there and so we've got a view target from there.
Now what we want to do is we want to figure out what camera we want to be setting the blend to.
Now if I had done this in the level blueprint I could just directly select a camera from
the level but there's no way to select a camera currently.
If I go into my map and if I go to the cinematics tab here on the place actors so make sure
you have place actors which is just a select mode.
I can find a camera actor, I can right click, I can pilot the camera and I can just put
it into some kind of location where I say I want to blend to this camera.
Now if I want to eject out of there now just by pressing that eject button on the top left
I'll call my camera something I'm going to call this wide shot even well it's a medium
close up but let's call it a wide shot on the bushes.
So I've given my camera a name but even if I have this selected I can't now add it to
my blueprint.
If I right click I can't add it to my blueprint whereas if I went to my level blueprint so
I go to blueprints up here open level blueprints and if I right click in some empty space I
have a direct reference to the bushes camera because this is the level blueprint.
This untitled here is referencing this untitled map name and so I have direct control so if
you're only doing something level specific it's a much cleaner and faster workflow just
to start adding stuff inside of this blueprint whereas if you want to do it through a blueprint
we're going to have to create a reference inside of this camera switch.
So what I'm going to do is I'm going to open up the BP camera switch if you don't already
I'm going to go to variables I'm going to click plus variable here and I'm just going
to call this maybe camera ref one it doesn't matter necessarily what you call this as long
as it's a consistent name so I'm just going to go to camera ref one as we've done previously
let's just give it a category straight away so I know I can keep everything organized
so I'm just going to give it a category of cameras and what I want to do is change the
variable type to a cine camera so the cine camera variable type is this actor and now
what I'm going to do is I'm going to create a soft object reference so if I hover over
cine camera actor you can create an object reference I prefer to use soft object reference
the reason for that is because the top object reference is a hard reference.
takes longer to process hard references and if the hard reference gets broken it can crash your
projects whereas if you use a soft object reference Unreal knows which reference it
should be using but it won't cause as many issues so moving forward just a good tip and
workflow practice is to create soft object references where you can so I'm going to click
create soft object reference I'm going to expose this variable as we did on our bush blueprint so
and then I'm going to compile and save and now if I go back into my map and I say let's drag and
drop the camera switch actor in here I just move it into a location and sometimes what I do as well
this isn't functional this is purely aesthetic so it's up to you if you do this but the BP
underscore camera switch I'm going to add a component on this component I'm going to type
billboard I'm going to add a billboard and by default it's called billboard I'm just going to
call this icon now if you want to assign custom sprites you can do by default this is a dinosaur
head which is a legacy Unreal Engine sprite but what I'm going to do is oh I'm going to drag and
drop the icon over the default scene root so I want to replace the scene root with this icon now
when I compile and save I have this little dinosaur head in my map so again you could
create your own icons for this camera switch blueprint and so you know exactly where this
blueprint is placed completely optional has no functional consequence other than usability but
that's a really good good tip to use what we'll see here though is we have a camera ref one here
which is what we called our first variable and it's got non selected now it's going to be very
easy to select the the first wide shot from this list if I click down the list because I've only
got one camera if you've got a map with say a hundred cameras you could search the specific
reference but if you're not sure what name you need you can also just pick the actor from the
scene so I'm going to select the pick actor from scene and I'm going to click that so now we've
assigned wide shot bushes to camera ref ref one what we want to do now is we want to add some kind
of event that fires when we load up the level so for now what I'll do is I'll just go and begin
play so if I actually just play this map to show you what happens first and foremost if I click play
nothing happens I've just got a fly around viewport I've just got some default game mode if I go back
and I've just hit escape there just to come out of it so if I go to BP camera switch I'm going to
right-click type begin play hit enter and then I'm going to drag off begin play set view target
which is I'm going to compile and save now we just need to set a new view target now I'm going to
hold ctrl and left mouse drag to camera f1 and because it's a soft reference we could create a
hard reference which would have been blue to blue but because it's a soft reference we first need
to drag off and resolve this so just type resolve hit enter now it creates a blueprint
blue pin sorry so this soft object reference resolves itself to say yes I exist now this is
the reference if it was a hard reference you could get validity issues if the camera reference gets
lost at any point by that I mean if that for example doesn't get filled out by someone and
it says a none that's a hard object reference to no cameras which can cause a project to crash
whereas if it's a soft object reference even if it was none you'd be fine unreal would just it
wouldn't work because there's nothing plugged in but it also would prevent stability issues but we
do know what our camera is we want to create wide shot bush we have a camera f plugged in here we
have our set view target I'm going to compile and save and now I'm going to play and we instantly
have that wide shot of the bushes and that's because it's fired on begin play so we can add
some more complex functionality for now but for now it's quite a lot of powerful blueprint
functionality going on we've got some kind of camera switch manager going on we've created a
camera reference and we've also got variables connected to this blueprint which can add some
starting functionality for a camera switch blueprint